[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to Eyes on
Enterprise, where
I'll be bringing on
my lovely colleagues
to talk about the
tech, strategies,
and best practices that are
helping to shape enterprises
today.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, developer advocate.
And today I have Sam Stoelinga
on the show, customer engineer.
And we're going to be talking
about hybrid and multi-cloud
and how to approach that.
So Sam, thanks for
being on the show today.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
thank you for having me.
Happy to talk about hybrid
and multi-cloud today.
And yeah, let's get started.
STEPHANIE WONG: First off, no
large enterprise, no matter how
well prepared, can simply
move to the cloud in one
fell swoop, even
if their goal is
to migrate completely
to the cloud, hence
multi-cloud and hybrid.
So can you help us
define both of those
in the context of an enterprise?
SAM STOELINGA:
Workloads and processes
are unique across
different enterprises.
And that's why you also see the
term hybrid and multi-cloud be
used inconsistently.
So let's start
with hybrid cloud.
So hybrid cloud is
really where you
have a private,
on-prem data center,
and you're using a public
cloud, and how can you
have workloads that
are interconnected
and be deployed across these
two different environments.
Multi-cloud, on the other
hand, is really focused on what
if you have several cloud
providers, public clouds,
and also, possibly, a private
cloud or on-prem data center,
and how can you use these
altogether for your workloads.
Multi-cloud, on the
other hand, can also
mean if you'd only have
one cloud provider.
But you want to make sure
that your workloads are
ready to be ported when needed.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
So what's interesting
here is it's
more about the architectural
portability and readiness
of your workloads.
And one other thing
you mentioned was it's
more about the extension of your
private network into the cloud
or from cloud to cloud.
SAM STOELINGA: Yes,
that's one technology
to enable a hybrid cloud.
So we have two
technologies that really
enable you to extend
your private data
center to the cloud,
where you can even
treat a cloud as
an additional rec
if you would like
to stay that way.
So there is a
dedicated interconnect,
and there's the cloud VPN.
And both allow you to [? span ?]
a private network that's
running on-prem and connect it
to the private network that's
running in Google Cloud,
which we call a VPC network.
And that allows you to
advertise the on-prem network
to the cloud and the
cloud network to on-prem.
So any users on-prem
can also directly access
any cloud service
that's exposed only
over to private VPC network.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now, it's
clear that, at this point,
there are a lot
of misconceptions
about hybrid and multi-cloud.
So I wanted to talk about
the top three misconceptions
that I've heard, and I want to
hear what you think of them.
So the first one is that
there is a hybrid product that
makes my workloads hybrid.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
so I've had questions
where I would get
asked, like, what
is your hybrid cloud product?
And then they would
assume that there
is a product that
takes their workload
and makes it automatically
run across their private data
center and on the public cloud.
And they would expect benefits
that they get out from it,
like lower cost, better
reliability, et cetera.
However, I noticed that
I don't think there are
sorts of product that exist.
Actually, hybrid cloud is more
about a set of technologies
that may or may not be adopted
by different kind of workloads.
Also let's say we have a
batch processing workload.
That workload [? needs to ?]
[? be ?] run every night.
And it needs to be
finished within four hours
before the next day begins.
The enterprise has
a hybrid strategy
that they want to
use their existing
investments for on-premise
as much as possible.
So every workload
owner is encouraged
to use that first, but
for any excess capacity,
they need to go to the cloud,
because they don't want
to invest more in
on-premise, but they
want to make sure to keep
the existing investments
and make the most out of them.
So what they do is they have
an interconnect and the burst
processing workloads spins
up more VMs in the cloud
and then it transfers--
it does some processing,
and it sends the
results back to on-prem.
So the data stays on-prem.
Some capacity is being
used from on-prem.
But the majority for this
work needs to be in the cloud
because otherwise, they couldn't
finish within four hours.
So it's a really good example of
one hybrid architecture that's
useful for this work.
However, for other workloads
you might see a different kind
of hybrid architecture.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
I think that's really
interesting, because again,
it's more about the
feature and technology that
enables you to burst or
have better redundancy
by moving to the cloud.
So I want to talk about my
second misconception, which
is that by moving
to the public cloud,
that inherently makes
your workloads publicly
facing to the internet.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
and, I mean, it comes
from the name of public cloud--
means everything has
to be public, right?
So I would say it's not unheard
of that people think that way.
However, it's not--
that's not true.
You can simply expose your
workloads over a VPC network
only and then bridge
that VPC network
if you're on-prem using the
interconnect or a cloud VPN
that we have talked
about previously.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now for
the third misconception--
moving to hybrid and
multi-cloud means
moving everything at once.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah.
I think that really
comes from the fact
that people have
workloads that always
have many other dependencies.
And these dependencies often
reside on-prem as well,
so they can--
they assume that the fact
that they move the workload,
they also need to move all
the dependencies with it.
However, that's not the case.
Like we explained earlier, we
have hybrid cloud connectivity,
which allows you to
move the workload
but still keep the
dependencies on-prem.
STEPHANIE WONG: Do
you mean like running
your legacy backend systems
on-premise or your database
on-premise and then
your Kubernetes Engine
front-end in the cloud?
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
I think that would
be a great example of how you
could migrate your workloads
with all its dependencies.
Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's
move on to deciding
on a strategy, because I know an
estimated 88% of organizations
are adopting multi-cloud today.
And that can be for
many reasons, one
being risk reduction--
they don't want to put
all their eggs in one basket.
Another being
architectural similarity,
like for like between clouds,
or maybe even best of breed
or feature availability
in each cloud.
Have you seen any other
motivating factors
for companies?
SAM STOELINGA: So I think
you mostly captured it.
Most customers, they want
to reduce the lock-in
they have to any vendor.
They want to have the leverage
over the vendors versus losing
that altogether.
And they want to be able to
choose the cloud provider that
provides them the best service.
STEPHANIE WONG: What about
maintaining consistency
across environments?
You need consistent
tooling that's
simple that allows you to manage
things, like access policies,
and you might have dependencies
between applications and needs
for performance and
latency requirements.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
I know, exactly.
And maintaining consistency
can be a challenge.
That's also why Google has
several tools available,
such as containers,
Kubernetes, and Anthos
that allow you to
maintain consistency
across different environments.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now
that we've talked
about the foundations of
hybrid and multi-cloud,
I do want to talk about
a specific case study.
What are some typical use cases
in which performance, storage
cost, or modernization
of existing apps
were key reasons to migrate?
SAM STOELINGA: So yeah, I'm
working with this customer
today.
They're trying to modernize
their [INAUDIBLE] on-prem IT
stack.
And they're running
a CI/CD workload,
Jenkins, currently on-prem.
And their technical
requirement is
where they need to be able to
access the on-prem artifact
storage, and the
on-prem users need
to be able to access the
Jenkins instance as well.
So with these requirements,
they came to us and said,
we want GKE on-prem.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
it was clear to them
that they needed to
continue running Jenkins
but on GKE on-premise.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah, well,
that's what they told,
but then we started
talking more and more.
And we found out
that, hey, we actually
can run all these things,
matching these requirements,
while still running
it on the cloud.
So we introduced this
customer to several features,
one of them being
GKE private masters
and private nodes, which
allows you to run GKE clusters
in a fully private fashion.
So none of the GKE workloads
are exposed publicly.
The GKE nodes themselves do not
even have a public IP address.
Everything is directly available
over the private network,
which is connected to on-prem.
And at the same
time, this allows
them to run Jenkins
on top of GKE
while still being able to
access the artifact storage.
So in this way, we had a hybrid
solution for this customer
by moving part of
their CI/CD stack
to the cloud, while still being
able to connect to on-prem.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's interesting.
And I think it
clarifies that you
do need to have a
product and networking
understanding to know that you
can actually restrict access
to public endpoints for
a private GKE cluster.
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah, yeah.
Networking experience
is always needed.
Even people think they
move to the cloud,
they don't need network
engineers anymore.
But networking knowledge is
required, even in the cloud.
STEPHANIE WONG: So let's
talk about migrations now.
In most cases, migrations is a
one-time, irreversible effort.
But with hybrid
and multi-cloud, it
makes it so that you
can move in phases now.
So I think portability
here is key.
But let's say I'm
an organization,
I want to make my
workloads portable,
what would be my
first step to do that?
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
so the first step
is to make sure that
your workload is
able to shift from one computing
platform to another platform.
In order to do that, you need
to separate the application
deployment and management
from the artifact of how you
delivered the software itself.
So there are many tools
that help you do that today.
And based on these tools,
we can form a tool chain
that helps you do this for any
VM or container-based workload
that you might have.
So I think key here
is understanding
that making your
workload portable
doesn't mean that you have
to make it cloud native.
This is often a effort that
is not significant to do.
And people can start doing that
today with the tools available.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK,
let's get specific.
Can you give me an
example of a tool chain
that you can use to build VM
images and deploy to any cloud
then?
SAM STOELINGA: There are a few
tools critical to start a tool
chain, mostly for, I would
say, there is a CI system,
there is the image builder,
there's a source version
control system.
And all this together
form a tool chain
that allows you to
build images that can be
deployed across any platform.
So let me give an
example of how you
would establish, like,
what tools would you
use for this tool chain.
So for the Image
Builder, there's
a great open source
tool by HashiCorp,
which is called Packer, which
takes in the application
deployment logic
and a base image
like, for example, Ubuntu or
another Linux system like RHEL,
and then builds an image
that can be deployed
across different platforms.
But it's always built using
the same deployment script.
So this really allows you
to build deployable images
for any cloud platform
or on-premise system.
The other system
is the CI system
which job is really taking the
latest commit from the source
version control
system and building
an image using the latest
application software.
And tying these together
allows you to build a pipeline
that you can now build
images automatically
for any platform whenever
a new commit gets
pushed to the source
version control system.
So that's really--
that's a simple example
of how you would do it.
And most customers,
they should choose what
they're already familiar with.
So if you're using
today Jenkins for CI,
you should continue using that.
However, if you're using
[? another tool, ?] you
can easily plug and
play different tools
to build such a pipeline.
STEPHANIE WONG: That
tool chain sounds
really great for workloads
that have an automated way
to deploy applications in VMs.
But what if I have an
application in a VM already
and I wanted to deploy
that to the cloud?
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
so that's actually
a pretty common
scenario, especially
for a large enterprise that buy
their software from a vendor,
and that vendor gave
them a VMware image,
and that VMware image doesn't
have the applications separated
from the image itself.
So they have no way of taking
the application and deploying
it [? on a ?] [? base image ?]
that can be deployed to another
cloud.
So the only solution is to
take that VM as is and somehow
get it to the cloud.
So there are two solutions
that Google Cloud offers today
to customers.
There's Migrate for Compute
Engine, which was previously
known as Velostrata, which
allows you to take a VM as is
and migrate it to the cloud.
And it has a lot
of cool features.
You can even migrate a VM,
[INAUDIBLE] in the original VM,
and test whether the
migration was successful.
So you can do a low risk
VM migration to the cloud.
The other solution
that I mentioned
is Anthos Migrate, which
allows you to take a VM
and convert it to
a container and run
that container in the cloud.
So both solutions allow
you to move workloads
from on-prem or out-of-cloud
providers to Google Cloud.
STEPHANIE WONG: So when would
you use one over the other
then?
SAM STOELINGA: The
two solutions are
different in what kind
of use case it supports.
So Anthos Migrate is a
solution that takes of a VM
and converts it to container.
And because it's a more
sophisticated technology,
it's more limited into what
kind of source workloads
it can support.
Migrate for Compute
Engine, on the other hand,
allows you to migrate much
bigger range of workloads.
I would say it support most
workloads that you can imagine.
STEPHANIE WONG: In
these cases, we're
talking about migrating
existing VM workloads.
But what if I want
to create a standard
for creating portable
applications that we
can move to any cloud?
SAM STOELINGA: So that's
really where containers fit in.
Containers really
forces everyone
within the company to
have a standard that
allows you to deploy the
container the same way
in any environment.
However, if you start
looking at how do I
manage a multi-host
environment, you
get into a more
sophisticated area.
And that's really where
Kubernetes comes in.
So Kubernetes solves
the chance of how can I
schedule containers across
a host, a set of host
in a cluster.
How can I do low balancing
across these containers?
How do I ensure that I
can scale out when needed?
STEPHANIE WONG: Kubernetes has
become the de facto standard,
but is there any difference
in developer experience?
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah.
Definitely.
And that's a good thing.
I think improvement in
developer experience
is always a good thing to have.
So developers can
really focus on writing
the code versus worrying about
where their code works well
in production and in
development because they have
the same container
that they build
that also gets
used in development
but also gets used
in production.
So they're able to improve
their production reliability
by having this kind of
developer experience.
STEPHANIE WONG: I think it
would be helpful to jump
into another scenario.
Let's say that I am
a company, and I've
containerized some
applications, but I'm still
primarily using monolithic
applications on-premise.
So how can I use Google tools
to help modernize and port
to the cloud?
SAM STOELINGA: We have a
modernization platform,
which we call
Anthos, which allows
you to modernize your
applications either on-prem
or in the cloud.
It's based on open platform.
So it says Kubernetes,
which we call Anthos GKE;
STO, which we call
Anthos Service Mesh;
and Knative, which
we call Cloud Run.
And these technologies really
allow you to modernize in place
and move to the cloud
when you're ready.
STEPHANIE WONG: What does
Anthos look like for IT
ops versus developers?
What's the user journey like,
when it comes to migrating?
SAM STOELINGA: So I've been
involved in a few Anthos
deployments.
And all of the cases
that I've been involved,
both developers and the
IT team have been engaged.
Actually, not just IT-- the
networking team, security team,
which you could
consider part of IT,
they've all been super
engaged, especially
during the initial
installation, but also
afterwards for making
sure that the Kubernetes
platform, the Anthos
platform stays running and up
and making sure the develop
have a proper experience.
IT operations are
always going to be
involved in those scenarios.
And developers,
on the other end,
are going to be focused on
making sure their workloads get
up and running
successfully on Kubernetes
and make sure they
stay up and running.
So they have different
roles, but they are still
both fully engaged.
Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: To
wrap up, what are
some of your views on the trends
for hybrid and multi-cloud?
SAM STOELINGA: Yeah,
so I have seen,
no matter which kind of
customer I work with,
you often see them
standardizing on Kubernetes
as the platform for workloads
to be running for the future,
but also for current
workers to be migrated to.
And even industries that are
traditionally been slower
to adopt newer
technologies, they're
also starting to
adopt Kubernetes
as the standard for their
internal applications
and external or any application.
Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: So for
those people in that bucket,
what can they do to get started
and get some value out of cloud
today?
SAM STOELINGA: I think that the
biggest thing they should do
is just get started
with a smaller pilot,
like find a workload that they
want to modernize right now,
get it running on Kubernetes,
see what benefits they
gain from doing that, and repeat
it for other workloads as well.
But really, sometimes it's more
of, just get it done and get
started.
STEPHANIE WONG: Sam, thank you
so much for being on the show.
SAM STOELINGA: No,
thank you for having me.
It was fun.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Everyone, check out
the articles on hybrid and
multi-cloud at the links below.
And comment with your own
experience with it as well.
Join us next time for
Eyes on Enterprise.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]